so how are you doing
i'm great excellent
i'm not gonna lie i i really like to
have a shower
that would be amazing just living on the
street make you little
it makes me very insecure because
when i'm dirty are i'm
are unclockable meaning
people will take advantage of the
opportunity
to tell you what's wrong with you out
here
and they'll laugh at you i had two old
gentlemen sitting on a corner this
morning and one tells the other
oh you're not that old are you and the
other one says ain't it danny versus
says
because you know the difference between
real and fake
and i was like you know what [ __ ] you
yeah i mean because that really does
hurt
and it makes me feel a certain kind of
way
and it makes me not be able to look
people in their face
and it makes me feel small and insecure
and i don't appreciate it and i deserve
better
i didn't ask for this when i got here
just
it just [ __ ] happens
so stephanie stephanie you uh you where
are you from originally you didn't grow
up here in san francisco
yeah i'm from dallas fort worth you're
from dallas
and how long you been here in san
francisco since september 2018.
so you're fairly new here yeah fairly
new
how was your childhood you had both your
parents as a kid oh yeah
my mom sold for avon and my dad worked
for six flags
and they didn't do drugs
didn't drink alcohol
they
fought a lot my dad was a cheater
and i started running away from home
and then they just kicked me out one day
and i've been on my own for 23 years
your parents kicked you out at what age
like i've been on my own for 23 years
have you been transgendered since since
when since been trying but it wasn't
always easy
my family wasn't accepting of things
like that my neighborhood definitely
would not have put up with something
like that
and um
i kind of came out here two years ago
[Music]
because you know my parents just on me
and everything and
i figured here's my golden opportunity
you know i need to make something of
myself and to transition and
it hasn't really worked out the way i
wanted it to
what hasn't gone right
it's a struggle
you know i live on the streets
people harass me constantly
they belittle me i've been hospitalized
this guy applied both my eyes and broke
my nose
put me in the hospital for four [ __ ]
days
i had my [ __ ] bruises for like
forever and i was so
unhappy i was i was i felt so insecure
and small
and like it's just like
there's no honor no matter what side of
the divide that you're on
those that have it those who don't
people are seem to be selfish and all
about themselves
and they don't care if you'll freeze to
death at night
as long as they can have a blanket
they'll steal yours
and it doesn't bother them they don't
lose a
second of sleep over it
and a few times i've almost left this
place
but there is nowhere else to go where do
you sleep at night
in friend's car it wasn't always like
that
but um
he's this rich gay guy
part of the macy family he's a
doublemint twin
and very jewish about his money
but he lets me sleep in his car so i
guess he's not so bad you know
um
what do you do you use drugs down here
no more than anybody else but
what are you gonna do
what do you do for money she live on the
streets
you got to do something i mean
i mean
it weren't for drugs
i
probably gone postal or [ __ ] jumped
off a cliff i fell in a crack in the
ground or
jumped off a cliff man it's crazy out
there
have you been transgender since since
what age roughly
my parents didn't put up with that they
didn't let me do it
i never got to do it as a child i never
really had a childhood
they would my parents were like over
obsessive about their punishments
they would ground me for five years
straight
you know which i've done five years
straight grounded in my room
um with nothing more than a bookshelf
no electronics no tv there's tv shows
that i know that existed but
i've never seen them i only can identify
them by the sound
of the beginning credits in music
because i would listen to it from
underneath the door i was always locked
in my room
i never got to have friends when friends
came to my house they were turned away
by my parents
they made me eat my dinner for breakfast
before i could have my breakfast if i
didn't finish my dinner
you know yeah i was getting to get away
and now i'm just
itching to go back indoors i hate it
what's been the roughest period of your
life
huh what's been the roughest time of
your life
now
and your transition is is are you doing
surgeries as well as
hormones not yet but you're taking
hormones they're not gonna get me
surgeries
i'm living on the [ __ ] streets
your friends stuff
my friends know screaming over i don't
have any friends
there's people that would call me their
friend but they're not my friends
you know
everybody wants something out here they
all have ulterior motive
it's ridiculous sometimes i don't
understand it
yeah i mean
there can't be one thing genuine out
here it's all arterial motive
there's always something behind every
[ __ ] thing
yeah i mean sometimes i just can't put
my finger on it
what the [ __ ] is the altera motive in
this but
you know there there is is it's
ridiculous
um it could be sex or
you know it's rough this is probably the
roughest time in my entire life yes
i feel like i'm still good looking but
because i'm
dirty and i'm on the street
i feel like no man wants me
that i can't get one
i sometimes feel like i'm stuck
forever
what's been the best time of your life
probably the first experts i was here
probably the first six months i was here
i was in bayview for like
six months to a year or whatever
i hooked up with this non-binary
here's a sweetheart but he was
polyamorous and i i got jealous
because i didn't understand
he left me
and he [ __ ]
just left
i have kind of been stuck out here since
you know sometimes i get suicidal out of
here
and when you're alone you don't have
anybody
you know it gives you plenty of time to
think
about how you would do it and don't get
me wrong
i know exactly how i would do it but i'm
thankful every day
that i don't you know i just wanted them
not to go into places and
tell them that i'm suicidal and you know
i'm smart enough and
i was raised better than that than to
take the easy way out
you know but you know i hope that
this switches out and touches someone's
heart
or that it changes people's
way of thinking because when people are
mean and divided and selfish
and prejudiced and they harass you
they don't know what you're going
through and they don't know you
and sometimes i feel like it would be
better if they just walked up to you
and said hey what's the matter
what can i do for you instead of always
always about me everything's always
about me out here man
so why don't people just stop for a
second and ask you what's wrong
what's wrong with you just something i
could do for you
that would probably make san francisco
a much better place
do you feel being transgender was
something that was
something you were born with yeah
absolutely yep
i wouldn't take it back for anything
that's who i am
there's nothing i want more in my entire
life
but i just don't know if i'm gonna be
able to achieve it
because they're not gonna let me get all
the services
out here on the street
you know
so i uh
i think my friend was telling me today
and our friend jasmine was murdered and
stabbed countless times and
found below the civic center or
something hotel or some [ __ ] and like
i was like i told him i don't want to
die
you know but you never know who's going
to pick you up out there man
you know i always when i'm angry i
always say things like
just my like a surreal color would pick
me up this evening and
i wouldn't be here on monday but i'm
only kidding
i mean that [ __ ] is [ __ ] scary as
[ __ ]
you know what i mean um
because there's a lot of [ __ ] crazy
people out here really [ __ ] crazy
you know i'm not one i'm not crazy
i'd like to believe that i'm
level-headed you know yeah i had a lot
of bad experiences
i've been beat up twice out here you
know
one by glide security and
at one night just trying to go to the
bathroom
and he followed me outside and
i was just teasing man i said well if
you don't let me go inside i guess i'm
gonna have to go right here
and he said if you do i said something
about punching me
i was like acted like i was pulling my
pants down but i didn't
and he socked me in the nose made me
[ __ ] myself right in front of the
building he was the only one working
that night and i should have [ __ ]
sued when they told me to
and then that same week skying the
ginger line i was
a little bit of a smart ass sometimes
but everybody knows i'm kidding
nobody punches me behind it or nothing
and i was like why
because you brought your trick over and
he [ __ ] just like went
punching the [ __ ] out of me man with
three citizens on my face
you know somehow i just opened my hands
and he punched me squirting and i was
broke it
fired both my eyes and had me depressed
for like
the next two weeks i was just sort of
[ __ ] depressed because it was like
he had rings on all of his fingers all
skull rings and
he had spike on whining it spiked
punctured me at the top of my nose
which is right here and put me in the
hospital they were going to keep me
longer but i chose to get up and go
so it's rough out here man you know and
a lot of the cultures don't understand
transgender they
they harass you when you walk down the
street not everybody is friendly
and the in the most homosexual
city in the world you'd be surprised but
there are so
many here that are against it and um
it's not based on any race or culture or
anything like that it's just
who certain people are and how they were
raised
and the things that they were brought up
to believe
they were planted in their heads
as young kids and they grew up to
believe these things and
now they can't walk past a person
like me without making her a harassment
i've been called he-man
because of my muscles
with your with your family disowning you
and and some of the
the acceptance you just don't get in
general as a transgender do you find
it's a very lonely life
i feel like transgender is a lonely life
i feel like i'm alone
what would you hope to see happen in
your future do you have dreams of
anything
of course not dreams like anybody else
um
right now i just want to get my [ __ ]
feet
i have a [ __ ] tired sometimes
this is just mentally exhausting
sometimes it's just mentally exhausting
i just want to get on my freaking feet
i just want to get on my feet for now
you know
i don't have the dreams i had a long
time ago
i don't really know what my dreams are
anymore
i just want to get on my feet and
go get my surgeries
change my [ __ ] appearance
fall off the edge of the planet and
start a new
life
all right stephanie well thank you thank
you for talking with me for sure
that's it that's it is there anything
else you'd like to share
you're cute thank you thank you for sure
i hope you could hear my voice on there
oh yeah
all right sorry about
being so emotional it's just it's rough
it was a nice talk oh thank you you're
so open
for sure
so let me give you something